we've heard it all before
record labels are going to die
and while non-fungible tokens otherwise
known as nfts may or may not be what
kills the traditional record label
they're already forcing the industry to
adapt we have watched technology change
the world and the labels be behind over
and over and over we're not content to
do that again depending on your point of
view it's either a revolution
a lucrative publicity stunt
or the latest gasp in the decades-long
undoing of the traditional music
industry most people know about nfts
because of the mania this spring
surrounding a few auctions of digital
art musical nfts are no different except
that in addition to any artwork they
come with audio files even though the
buyers of these nfts are just anonymous
numbers floating in the blockchain ether
musical acts can use that access to
market and sell new music fresh artwork
concert tickets and even old-fashioned
merchandise done right nfts offer the
ease and ubiquity of internet
distribution somewhat like napster but
with the digital rights protection built
in
think itunes but without apple
we've already seen a growing list of
startups targeting this base of
blockchain as a distribution method for
music
jay-z mark cuban ashton kutcher and
others have already invested nearly 100
million dollars in a number of companies
using blockchain as a form of music
distribution
as everyone from musicians to managers
and even labels themselves rush to cut
out as many middlemen as possible or
keep from being cut out the future of
music weighs in the balance
to understand how nfts are changing the
music business you first have to
understand how the music business
operates today
currently labels take home the vast
majority of the recording profit roughly
85 of album sales after expenses go back
to the businesses
the labels
not the musicians the artists
leaving those musicians to divide what
little remains between songwriters
agents and managers the rest they earn
on the road
an important distinction to make here is
that some musicians are doing nfts as
art while other musicians are doing nfts
as music
so what we're talking about here is
really the second category this is
potentially really powerful because it's
a new way to distribute the music itself
and not just a new way to sell artwork
and other digital objects
when i spoke with kings of leon drummer
nathan falwell he had this to say about
the impact of nft albums and songs on
the music distribution industry
record deals have lost their value in a
way whereas 20 years ago the thought of
getting a record deal you're like
we've got it made we're gonna go sell a
million records and we're gonna make
college money and we're gonna and bands
were able to do that but nowadays
it has lost its value in the sense that
a kid can make a record on garageband
and put it out on tick-tock or put it
out on as an nft or put it out in any
form it's almost like they don't need to
rely on
the record industry as much as they used
to
which in turn i think is making the
record industry kind of panic a little
bit
record companies are eyeing the rise of
nfts as possibly more dangerous than the
pirated mp3 files that sent the industry
into a death spiral 20 years ago but
also potentially as miraculous as the
streaming technology that has since
revived it
each of the three major music companies
have set up nft task forces they've
brought in everything from the law
departments to sales and marketing to
figure out how to not only keep from
being disrupted but to ensure that they
hold on to their existing market share
the most advanced team is at warner
music helmed by the chief digital
officer juana ruxandra who in addition
to making the first nft investment by a
label is working with her competitors to
reimagine the entire music business one
of the things that has been the downfall
of the music industry is that we compete
very heavily against each other and then
tech comes and they like eat our lunch
right and we're still competing with
each other and won't talk i think it's
important to note though that this isn't
the first time that technologists have
claimed that music industry was on its
back heels in fact we've seen this many
many times in the past cds did not kill
the music industry streaming did not
kill the music industry each time we've
seen the potential death of music
industry heralded we've actually been
reminded of the value that they bring in
fact these big bad evil companies still
exist for a reason and that's that
they're really helping out their
musicians but what this technology could
do
is make it easier for the undiscovered
talent to find their audience in the
first place
you